[Music]
it's
on
[Music]
go
thank you very
much have to turn him you have to cross
check that other arm you can't be here
and do
it so either do you should take on
proper where this leg goes back so if
you pay
attention one you're in that angle here
you see this angle is
[Music]
where if you want to Ed me then you
can't e me forward cuz the other hand
right there
boom kind you give me this way and you
get that same angle you just further out
okay
this pin depends on their
flexibility okay you're not turning them
over there's a vector going this
way so if I and you can play with the
wrist too so as you're coming down I can
start attacking this way so there's a
pin on there but he can't move
forward he can't Turtle up and do
anything with it go ahead okay if he's
really flexible you can come across you
come across the body but you see the
same
Vector turn
boom now if I just do it here straight
down straight down he can uh slide
forward and then he changes the angle of
the PIN see so this Vector has to come
this way so I can do it this way or I
can move it across my body and get it
even
better there's another one you see
it see there see
Americana
point
is contact with him Americana
again rewind
this okay so you're going around the
Americana you just got to get yourself
there it's right
there
versus this
stuff turn your head okay and you're
going this way or you get the bend it's
thing very
common but he can slide forward and the
pin's gone come back and of course you
can gry roll so you're going to roll
over that shoulder Turtle up and
roll
roomp here is the Americana room right
there so you want to break it right if
you want the pin you can't you got to
come out of
that okay I just take it across his body
see how I let it unbend and I take it
across this body in this variation I
have this pin but it's still going that
way see I let it out then I come
across this
way
okay we're going to I'll get to that
part next but see where he is you always
throw him on wonder you if you're going
to do a standing pit that's that's where
your Stomps are and your kicks you don't
throw him away from you okay and so for
the same
reason I'm not going to Ed me and t con
because go
back as soon as I ten con I'm not under
him you think I'm side of him and then
we already know that that's not going to
work he's just going to go forward or
roll so to help you learn this maneuver
think of standing over him and stomp it
on his face
okay pop right under me okay he's right
under
me and then I keep myself over
him so I'm here go back
rewind As I push this this
over down you see that he's staying
under me okay
rewind he goes oh he his momentum's
coming over and here is that ground path
I'll I'll loosen that okay here's that
ground po
projection then I go around that energy
though this foot goes around him and now
you end up in the
pin but you're over him so my
my my kinesthetic index point is that
you stay over him
okay no don't go around
himom put him under you and then you go
over
him so it's 5 foot maneuvers you know
the row
one you're going to pop him down and
then you're going to e me so you get
over him
here and we'll do we'll focus on this
one it's got to go to the pin okay so
for UK if you bring this knee up towards
your hip you can change sides and get a
little slap but there's not
much boom I
boom you see I go I go over him move the
hand over come
back okay try that try that index point
now we'll do that Amic version okay so
the difference
is that I'm not going to straighten his
arm so on the last
one I'm going to project boom over okay
on this one I don't straighten his arm
you you want to keep the bend you're not
going to come
down
boom and it's right here so that same
step that you did you do it when he's
not on his on his belly okay and then
it's right here as you go boom stay
there go into your
back and let this
one
okay there it
is it comes towards the inside of your
body towards the inside of your body
this
way
this okay so the same step put on your
hip and it goes to the inside of your
body but go really slow and light
because the hips and legs are way
stronger it comes on way faster and
harder
okay so again I'll give you some index
on this one Boom the thumb hand Don't
Let Go thumb hand don't let
go you get one step and it's right there
okay get take the slack out by dropping
your weight cuz you are pinning and then
you do the technique by turning your
hip
boom I stuck with that one so now I come
underneath here okay this one goes
outside the hip don't let go the thumb
hand drop your weight control the elbow
and turn your
hip One Step
underneath you're here boom pop drop
turn I note on either one that you're
doing so you shove them over and you
bring that hand around pull your other
hand out can you touch your feet touch
my feet do what you want do what you
want with your feet yeah just cuz he can
touch you doesn't mean he's going to do
something with it you're going rust his
arm and
uh a lot of times in dojo Arts you do a
lot of scops right well you're going to
take his attention when you break his
arm he going to let go he'll forget
about your foot okay and uh the same
thing would go on this one okay so he
can reach up maybe he's trying to grab
my balls or something oh you think he's
going to forget about my balls as I rip
his arm off your shoulder got it uh the
transition
we know we want that angle
cancellation and do it to the
degree that you would if you were in
range get the Cy hole
going don't have a it and then come
around this far you're all jacked up
here all the way so this can just come
up
easily it's the outward
spiral so our spiral our spiral and then
hold your grip if you
want grab but don't pull you're going to
pry
out this way and
around keep your grip boom I'm turning
prying out and there it is the
[Music]
Thro
don't come
[Music]
off you twist around boom
on Boom twist
[Music]
around boom boom twist
around
twist
TST okay let's try that hand
release it's very common in life he'll
do a front brake fall so he'll you don't
know what to do so I got to tell you
okay you're going to turn your foot that
way and then there's the fall do you see
that
okay but he can't do that because of the
angle cancellation turn your foot you
see so usually there's no angle
cancellation and then he could turn his
body that way and then he can do it okay
but moreover uh people that you're not
going to spin someone top to turby with
the wrist joint it doesn't really work
that way in the street okay um it will
on the elbow on the shoulder but the
wrist joint is just too small to get
that toxy effect
okay so this pin here is not going to be
something that he choreographs into the
fall then it has to
work and if you turn that you do the
next thing that you can get away with
cuz he's going to fall anyways is you're
on both sides of the arm do you see that
of the hand and you kind of just pull it
well if you get on both sides of the arm
if you get on both sides of the hand you
see you're here there's not much angle
cancellation to him in the first place
so you he could probably punch me boom
okay but if you were to get where I
can't get on the other side I have to be
on the back of the hand you can see how
much more angle cancellation there is so
he tries to punch it's a lot harder to
do
okay so for those reasons make sure you
get a good angle
cancellation you're coming around and
you should end up on the back of his
hand back
here and this is not a
twisting but a rolling over so you more
kind of thinking
sh you
see boom here
down it
[Music]
goes so be on the back of the hand here
and down it
goes bo back of the hand and down It
Go
okay and so look for the back break ball
so you're not shortcutting things not
the front breake